But, uh, moving on, uh, let's go over to Connor's list, which is rather.
Would be a first please. So do you want to cry when I think I need to
now take bullying from you guys every week.
I need alcohol from the,
the show to kind of fence off two boys a week. What do you mean?
We've both gone so much from you because every weekend Kotter has to
defend his take. Well, I mean, it's kind of hard because.
I'm looking at this list right now and so far,
there's a lot of shows that you haven't even given us.
Cool. Yeah. I think there's a lot of them. I'm just like, this is so.
I don't even want to give it a like, hold up.
Don't tell me anything until I've had my beer.
Okay. No, no, no. We're starting now. We're starting now.
You better prepare your anus here. Like. No, an eight.
Hey, the bucket. No Stan gave bucket in the States.
Joey you'll taste the at the top is so much better. Yeah.
I don't know why I did that. I mean, you know, clearly I was a fool.
I don't know who that person is.
Who signed into my account and changed my school. I love the. They gave buck.
Him on a Guthrie, a highest score than pocket knife.
Clean it off. The story of 10 is on.
Me for liking climate. Yeah.
The first season is. What do I give that? Give it a score.
It's so forgettable. I didn't even want to write that.
Show bits. If I could write that I did that like a seven or an eight.
That was a fun show. Yeah, that was great. That's a fun show. Okay.
Why the did I give see the money of the soul? Impossible control and eight
[inaudible].
Never even finished that. Okay. Kochia sees them one and two. The same score.
Wait, did I really? Yeah. You did. Second thing.
I immediately noticed after our discussion,
like we just had Pokemon for.
[Inaudible] probably explain why that is the case. Right?
Because this was made in 2014. It was probably the age of like,
I'm a big boy now pick one, pick one.
That's old con that's child caught of me. Adult Connor. I don't like Pokemon.
I'm a man. I thought you were my boy. No, I am.
I wish I would actively change that to a 10 if I could.
Really 10. Okay. One, one thing. I, one thing I find hilarious.
Right. But come on because I can't be,
I have to talk about scores.
No, my own Connor has given steins Gates and sought out online.
The same score of eight.
Yeah.
[inaudible].
Well, not in line season one. And.
Joe is just having an aneurysm. Right? Listen, I can explain you.
Keep it the same. Please explain it.
Okay.
Question you giving stains. Get an eight. Okay. That's fine. I meant to 10.
[Inaudible]. I almost think, you know, what, if I had genuine, I
, I enjoyed soda online, but if I went back and watched it, I'm sure. You know, I would be like, what the is this? But I enjoyed it for
like what it was. I liked the idea. Cause it's
my first ever like video game anime. Right
, right. So it was fun. And then, you know, you think about it more and then you
think about Carytown and you're like, wow. Really Gabi. But at the
time, yeah. I mean, at the time everyone everyone's.
We've all gone through the stage where we thought saw us in line was a cool
concept. Whack. Back when it was a cool concept, admittedly,
as much as I'm known as the guy who publicly hates, sold online,
like I I've said that like first couple of episodes,
really great buildup of the premise.
And then it kind of just fell apart after a while when they were like,
let's make Kirito the edgiest protagonist alive.
And then that's when I was like, okay.
I mean.
You had a great premise and you just kind of ruined it with the worst,
main character.
I have no idea why I gave back. And when I got three at nine, I would never,
ever do that. Why would you give it like a five? Why boring shirt?
That's boring, man. That's so boring. Yeah. But you have to understand,
this is a man who skipped story. What I want to know is how the do you watch?
Why did you even watch it? You watched an animated light, novel.
Gotcha. And then I watched like the next three seasons or so.
And how did you manage that? How did you manage that?
I'm just confused a lot of the time,
but I also just like thought a lot of it was weird. Like, cause this is the,
you have to bear in mind.
This is the first time I'd ever seen any anime where like there was a
protagonist or whatever. He was just like touching a kid, like the ghost skills.
And I was like, I was like, Whoa, what the? What the is this? I'm like, well,
why is he want like in this child porn bro. It's all right, man.
It's a deconstruction of heroin.
What I want to know is how you got the patients to do it because even me, well,
you bet again, back in the age of like when you're an anime fan,
you can kind of like put up with anything because you've just gotten into it.
Yeah. And that was when I watched it.
Cause it always high up on the list and that,
that might've been the thing that made me be like, you know what, no,
I'm not watching it. Now.
He uses me. Right.
Is that like you gave [inaudible] and I would assume the majority of them will
have Atari series, like a mid school. Yeah. But you love cuts on a Godfrey.
Catatonic Godfrey. He's like awesome. But it's.
The same style. It's the same style.
It's done like a million times better. It's so much more entertaining.
The back of what I got, she ever was.
I'm not saying cuts on the gutter is bad or anything. Yeah. They're both.
Great. Because like, I guess in my mind, when I think of like on, I got that,
it just feels like a Quentin Tarantino film. Like when I like,
like the dialogue is really important. It's like the one that like,
I don't really like it when seeing,
how did you not find that with the Mormon Atari series?
Because I didn't find the dialogue interesting in like Catan,
I got through like the one selling point. Find it.
Interesting.
I was just waiting. I, you know,
I was sold and rice circulation came on and I'm like, yo, this is.
I went to see her man and give, give us the water. Yeah.
I needed after I needed, after the aneurysm, I'm happy.
And I got three, right. Was like legit. Oh. Okay. I made my three by three.
I'll see, I didn't put the catatonic. I thought again,
because I just didn't forgot it existed,
but that would go with my three by three. So ketonic Guthrie is like,
it gave me everything that like I love about like kill bill and pulp fiction in
anime foam kind of store with a setting that I love, which is like samurai.
I love samurai.
I mean, again,
I'm not disagreeing with you on that a hundred percent agree with all of them.
Yeah. I'm just saying like, it's, it's both a lot of words. It's both,
it's both weird. Yeah. It's both characters. That's very serious shaft, no cuts.
And I got to his North studio shaft.
And I got three. I just really enjoyed so much more than I ever did.
The monograph series.
That's the closest you've come to enjoying just reading words then. Yeah.
There's a lot of the action was really good.
Three and it made sense on the story.
Action in the morning. I'm sorry. I'm going to Guthrie.
Serious action was insane. Come on man. It's I don't know why,
but yet the action was far better than I had any rights. Yeah, exactly.
Sharp was like, all right, I'm gonna flex real quick. Like that,
that fight where it was like [inaudible] versus like,
I think it was Karen in the second season.
It was like the big brother versus I can't even remember. No,
the fight was a combo. Yeah. You remember the monkeys?
That was brutal, man. I don't even find, remember this.
I'll show you afterwards and you'll, you'll learn to appreciate it.
Let's say though,
the toothbrushing is part of the thing that made me like curious about hen Thai.
I was like, Oh, this is actually.
Kind of honestly like the toothbrush scene. I'm gonna say it's hot.
I feel like it birthed so many degenerates because that us culture was born.
Dust culture was born. Thanks to the toothbrushing. That is a classic scene.
And that scene as being like the classic scene, um,
I noticed you gave Nora gummy a 10. Did I remaster people?
Who are you and how much time did you spend on Tumblr?
Honestly, I don't know what mindset I was in. There was,
I don't think there's any point in my life where I genuinely liked.
In my opinion, the only 10 out of 10 aspect about an origami is the opening.
Yeah, that was good.